so I I have told people that the highest
compliment I've ever gotten from anyone
at any time was from you when you said
that you were writing the Martian
putting down you know laying down some
science to track and you imagined I was
looking over your shoulder oh yeah
what if that's tyson research on the
brink of tweeting about some mess up in
your book yeah you didn't want that I
didn't want that I don't want that so it
is that am I still there oh yeah oh yeah
no no I you're still there
you're still there on my shoulder I in
fact Artemis is even more scientifically
accurate than the Martian it the Martian
projected forward some technologies like
ion in giant propulsion and ER and I
completely ignored the effects of
radiation on I just made this magical
have material that would stop radiation
I get offered no explanation in Artemis
I didn't I didn't even do that I said
like all right you know Artemis has the
the whole thickness to protect people
from radiation when you go out on an e
vai calculated let's say you're a
tourist and you go out on an e VA and
one of those hamster balls you don't
have a bunch of like protection from a
traditional UVA suit how much radiation
do you get turns out over a two-hour e
VA during the lunar daytime you would
get about the same amount of radiation
as a getting a set of dental x-rays so
that's fine that's the measure but I
checked and the reason I checked is
because I knew you'd check but you know
you know I get I get misunderstood in
many of my I'm there to just enhance
people's appreciation of the book or of
the movie and and I'm you know I get
characterized as a buzzkill but no just
keeping everybody keeping them on is
keeping see I'm I'm I guess I'm in some
I don't know if I'm in a minority or
whatever I'm in the opposite camp I love
I love that I love what other people
apparently consider a buzzkill
I I'm like yeah you tell him you know
because because
because because it drives me crazy like
what what really bugs me and a story
isn't so much physics inaccuracies I can
accept a warp drive you know I got no
problem with that you know for
suspension of disbelief no problem what
bothers me is inconsistencies yep so if
you can go faster than light I remember
there's one episode of Star Trek where
they're in the you know classic track
they're in the enterprise right it can
go warp I forget what classic Trek
Enterprise could go warp something like
that and but then at one point there
you're like okay we need to get from
Mercury to earth and it like took them a
while and I'm like wait a minute okay no
mercury is like seven light minutes from
Earth and you're going many many times
the speed of light is they're gonna take
you a while so yeah that one's it's lit
by yeah there's the other episode where
they wanted to magnify the sound of
people's heartbeats to find out where
the alien was a spacecraft and was it
Spock or Kirk said this device magnifies
the sound by one to the twelfth power
one to the twelfth power
yeah excellently I'm 1 times 1 times 1
times 10 yeah well then I thought okay
they just misread it and then there's a
similar error in another episode yeah
where it was like 1 to the 9th power so
somebody just didn't get that yeah well
I remember in a book now that's not fair
bagging on Star Trek books cuz there's
so many baby I remember one of the Star
Trek books Kirk says Scotty I want every
ohm of power to the shield ohm of power
yeah so to which I imagine Scotty seemed
well he wants maximum resistance so I
guess I'll just turn them off